Die neuen Raumanzüge, die die NASA jetzt
vorgestellt hat, sind echte Allround-Talente:
Mit ihm können die Astronautinnen und Astronauten
bei der nächsten Mondmission wohl geschmeidig
über die Oberfläche laufen - anstatt so
zu hüpfen wie ein Hase wie damals noch die
Apollo-Generation.
Der orangefarbene sogenannte “Orion Crew
Survival Suit” soll auf dem Weg in Richtung
Mond getragen werden und würde das Überleben
der Crew für ganze sechs Tage sichern - selbst,
wenn der Druck innerhalb des Raumschiffes
plötzlich und unerwartet sinkt.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Einer der beiden neu konstruierten Raumanzüge
der NASA heißt “Exploration Extravehicular
Mobility Unit (xEMU)” und ist weiß, rot
und blau.
Und er macht künftigen Astronautinnen und
Astronauten das Leben wohl sehr viel einfacher.
Denn im Vergleich zum “Apollo-Modell”
beschert er deutlich mehr Bewegungsfreiheit
und ist zudem passend für Frauen UND Männer.
Eine echte Premiere, denn das hatte sich in
der Vergangenheit ja als kompliziert herausgestellt.
Zur Erinnerung: Erst im März diesen Jahres
(2019) musste die NASA den ersten geplanten
Weltraumeinsatz, der nur von Frauen durchgeführt
werden sollte, absagen.
Der Grund: nicht genügend passende Raumanzüge.
Doch damit ist jetzt Schluss.
Denn die neuen Raumanzüge in Einheitsgröße
lassen sich ohne Probleme an die jeweilige
Astronautin bzw. an den jeweiligen Astronauten
anpassen.
Doch nicht nur das: Die NASA-Ingenieurin Kristine
Davis zeigt bei der Präsentation, wie sie
sich in dem Anzug bücken kann und Gegenstände
vom Boden aufheben kann - ohne dabei das Gleichgewicht
zu verlieren.
Eine extrem wichtige Sache für die Erkundung
des Mondes.
Dazu Kristine Davis: “Die Mobilität ist
sehr wichtig für unsere Arbeit.
Wenn man einen Stein aufheben möchte, wenn
man ein wissenschaftliches Instrument einsetzen
möchte, dann braucht man diese Oberkörperbeweglichkeit."
Auch die Arme über den Kopf zu heben, scheint
keine Probleme zu bereiten.
Und noch eine entscheidende Sache ermöglicht
dieser neu entwickelte Raumanzug.
Dazu Jim Bridenstine, der Chef der NASA: “Wenn
wir uns an die 'Apollo'-Generation erinnern,
erinnern wir uns daran, wie Neil Armstrong
und Buzz Aldrin wie Hasen über die Mondoberfläche
gehüpft sind.
Jetzt wird es uns möglich sein, über die
Mondoberfläche zu laufen.
Das ist ganz anders als bei den früheren
Anzügen."
Er betont noch einmal, dass die NASA die Landung
auf dem Mond quasi nur als ein Zwischen-Ziel
sieht: “Letztendlich lautet das Ziel: Wir
wollen zum Mars.
Und um zum Mars zu gelangen, müssen wir den
Mond als Testgelände nutzen."
Doch das Modell “Exploration Extravehicular
Mobility Unit (xEMU)” beschert nicht nur
mehr Bewegungsfreiheit.
Hinzu kommen zwei weitere technische Neuigkeiten:
Zum einen schützt der Anzug die Astronautinnen
und Astronauten vor extremen Temperaturen.
Umgebungstemperaturen von minus 157 Grad bis
hin zu plus 121 Grad soll durch den modularen
Aufbau des Anzuges für die Menschen in ihm
auszuhalten sein.
Dazu NASA-Ingenieurin Amy Ross: “Wenn wir
auf den Mars fliegen, dann brauchen wir eine
neue Isolierung, denn dort gibt es eine Atmosphäre".
Die zweite technische Neuerung führt dazu,
dass das System zur Absorption von Kohlendioxid
besser funktioniert.
Das Gas entsteht bei der Atmung der Astronautinnen
und Astronauten und konnte von den bisherigen
Raumanzügen nur bis zu einem bestimmten Sättigungsgrad
aufgenommen werden.
Das neue Modell “xEMU” aber ist in der
Lage, das Gas nach Außen ins All abzugeben.
Neben diesem neu entwickelten Raumanzug wurde
der Öffentlichkeit eine weitere Entwicklung
präsentiert: der orangefarbene “Orion Crew
Survival Suit”.
Gedacht ist dieser für die Reise zum Mond,
die ja für das Jahr 2024 geplant ist.
Erstmals seit 1972 sollen dann wieder Menschen
auf dem Mond sein.
Auf dem Weg dorthin könnten die Astronautinnen
und Astronauten den orangefarbenen Anzug in
der Raumfähre tragen.
Im Worst Case - beispielsweise, wenn ein Meteorit
die Außenwand des Raumschiffes beschädigt
oder gar durchdringt - könnte der “Orion
Crew Survival Suit” das Überleben der Crew
sichern.
Und zwar bis zu sechs Tage lang.
Denn in einem Notfall, kann der Anzug die
Astronautinnen und Astronauten stabilisieren.
Beispielsweise, wenn es zu einem plötzlichen
unerwarteten Druckabfall kommt.
Es scheint ja doch langsam konkreter mit der
Landung auf dem Mond 2024.
5 Fakten über die erste Mondlandung.
Anklicken, anschauen und Astro Comics TV abonnieren.
Kostet ja nichts.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!